>> Sally: What are you working on?
>> Dude: I've got a great new idea.
I'm going to make cocoa beans
that reproduce as fast as viruses.
That way, we'll have enough cocoa beans
to make as much chocolate as we want!
>> Sally: You know how much I like chocolate!
Explain your project a little more.
How are you going to engineer this yummy idea?
>> Dude: Well viruses reproduce really
fast so I thought I could take that part
from a virus and put it into a cocoa plant.
>> Sally: Plants are pretty safe to
work with but viruses can be dangerous.
Which virus were you thinking about using?
>> Dude: Well I read that Ebola
virus has a short sequence that...
>> Sally: ...EBOLA!?!
Ebola is a bio-safety level FOUR agent.
>> Dude: Well the worst are level
five, so I thought it was safe enough.
>> Sally: Level five?
There is no bio-safety level five.
You'd need lots and lots of training to
work in any level three or four facility...
...and you'd have to wait a few years
since they don't let minors in those labs.
>> Dude: DD: But there was
this show I saw on TV where...
>> Sally: What you see on TV and
in movies can be very deceiving.
But let's talk about all the bio-safety levels.
If we're going to make your viral cocoa
beans, we need to come up with a way
that keeps everyone safe,
inside the lab and outside too.
>> Dude: OK.
I do know that biosafety is a combination
of safe lab practices and techniques,
wearing the right safety equipment, and working
in a lab designed to contain the experiment.
But with biosafety level
1 that just means a room
with screened windows and a door that closes.
That doesn't sound like much.
>> Sally: That's because BL1 experiments
use only well-characterized microbes
that don't make a healthy person sick.
But remember, there's no
eating or drinking in the lab
since you wouldn't want to eat your experiments.
>> Dude: When do I get to
wear a lab coat like yours?
>> Sally: If you're working at biosafety level
2, you'll have to wear it, and gloves, too,
since some BL2 agents can be infectious.
BL2 labs have impervious benches and most of
the work is done in biological safety cabinets.
Lots of BL2 workers also get immunizations
if they'll be working with certain agents.
>> Dude: I hate getting shots.
>> Sally: Well, not all level
2 agents require immunizations.
Really, the rules for BL1
and BL2 are pretty basic
because the agents have minimal
risk associated with them.
But let's think for a minute
about what biosafety you'd need
for your mash-up of a virus with a cocoa plant.
>> Dude: Well maybe more protective clothes,
like the workers in bio-safety level 3 labs.
They wear full suits and
maybe masks or something.
It's nothing I can't handle.
Imagine me in a space suit!
Very cool!
And think about how much chocolate we'll have!
>> Sally: Earth to Dude!
Level three agents are very serious, potentially
lethal, and level four agents, like Ebola virus,
have such a high lethal risk
that there are only a few places
in the world where they are studied.
Restrictions for working with
these agents are very tight.
Everything entering or leaving BL3
and BL4 labs has to be decontaminated.
Sometimes the lab has to be in its
own building to control foot traffic.
I know I don't want to work where there
are double door entries and airlock rooms.
>> Dude: I think that sounds like fun...
>> Sally: ...If you are so excited
about the protective clothing,
we can always be overly cautious
in a level 1 or 2 facility.
But can't we find another
way to make more cocoa beans?
>> Dude: OK.
>> Sally: Maybe we can find another
virus that's not so dangerous
and we can keep working on your chocolate idea.
Let's start looking in here.